WHEN YOU CALL THEIR LOSS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS?
BECAUSE THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
THESE FAMILIES.
JOINING US NOW, TONIGHT, NINE
BRAVE AMERICANS WHOSE LOVED ONES
WERE KILLED BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THE ONES YOU ARE SAYING
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
INCLUDING WENDY AND DJ CORCORAN,
THEIR SON PIERCE, 22 YEARS OLD,
WAS JUST KILLED THIS PAST
DECEMBER 29TH BY A SUSPECTED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT IN KNOXVILLE.
HE WAS DRIVING ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF THE ROAD.
AT 22 YEARS OLD.
WE ARE ALSO JOINED BY LAURA
WILKERSON, HER SON JOSHUA WAS
BEATEN AND STRANGLED AND SET
AFLAME, ON FIRE, BY A CLASSMATE
WHO WAS IN THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
JOSHUA WAS 18 YEARS OLD.
THEN WE HAVE STEVE RANA BACK,
HIS SON, GRANT, RAISING MONEY
FOR COLLEGE, WORKED
OVERNIGHT IN A CONVENIENCE
STORE, SHOT BY AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT ROBBING THE STORE
WHERE GRANT WAS WORKING
OVERNIGHT.
THE MIDNIGHT SHIFT.
AGNES IS ALSO WITH US, HER SON,
RONALD DA SILVA, WAS SHOT IN A
DRIVEWAY BY AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
GANG MEMBER WHO HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN DEPORTED.
LET'S INTRODUCE MICHELLE, HER
DAUGHTER, SARAH, WAS KILLED BY
AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO WAS
DRUNK DRIVING, AND HE
DISAPPEARED AFTER POSTING BAIL.
WHY DID HE GET BAIL?
WE ARE ALSO JOINED BY MARIANNE
MENDOZA, HER SON, POLICE
SERGEANT BRANDON MENDOZA WAS
KILLED BY A DRUNK DRIVER, IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, AND
IMMIGRANT, IN A HEAD-ON
COLLISION.
ALSO WITH US, MAUREEN MALONEY,
HER SON, MATTHEW, DENISE,
LITERALLY KILLED BY AN ILLEGAL
ALIEN DRUNK DRIVING.
LASTLY, WE INTRODUCE SABINE
DURDEN, HER SON, DOMINIC, WAS
KILLED IN A COLLISION BY AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO HAD HER  T
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO HAD HER  O
PRIOR DUI CONVICTIONS.
A 911 DISPATCHER.
THEY ARE ANGEL MOMS WHO SERVE AS
DIRECTOR FOR ADVOCATES OF
VICTIMS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ALIEN CRIMES.
THEY ALL JOIN US.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
ANYTHING WORSE, JUST A GENERAL
QUESTION, I'M A PARENT, I HAVE
TWO KIDS, I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANYTHING WORSE THAN LOSING HER
SON OR DAUGHTER, RIGHT?
IT'S NOT NATURAL, WE DON'T BURY
OUR KIDS, RIGHT?
I'VE MET MANY MOTHERS AND
FATHERS OF SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN,
THEY GO THROUGH THIS, BUT THEY
KNOW THEY ARE GOING INTO A RISK.
WHEN YOU FIND OUT THAT IT IS
SOMEBODY THAT WAS ALREADY IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, AND
THEY ARE HERE ILLEGALLY, IN YOUR
CASE, YOU ARE LIKE THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THIS CLUB THAT NOBODY
WANTS TO BE PART OF.
YOU JUST LOST YOUR SON, RIGHT,
WENDY?
ON THE 29TH?
FIRST, HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP,
THIS IS STILL NEW TO YOU?
>> I THINK WE ARE STILL NUMB,
STILL IN SHOCK ABOUT IT TO A
DEGREE.
IN FINDING OUT SO MANY PEOPLE
ARE HURTING OVER THE SAME THING,
IT IS JUST --
>> Sean: PAINFUL.
EVERY DAY YOU WAKE UP WITH IT.
>> THE REALITY HITS EVERY
MORNING THAT IT IS A REAL.
>> Sean: THAT IS THE HARDEST
TIME, THE MORNING WHEN YOU WAKE
UP.
>> WHEN YOU WAKE UP, YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO WAKE UP
FROM A BAD DREAM, AND THEN THE
TEARS, AND YOU REALIZE IT IS
REAL.
>> Sean: 14 YEARS, THE DRIVER
IN THIS CASE, WAS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND COME HERE
ILLEGALLY, AND BECOME A
PRODUCTIVE CITIZEN, BUT HE CHOSE
NOT TO.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT HIS PAST
CRIMINAL RECORD?
THEY WON'T REVEAL IT?
>> THEY ARE SAYING THERE IS NO
CRIMINAL RECORD, THAT IS HOW HE
WAS ABLE TO STAY HERE FOR THIS
LONG, BECAUSE THERE WAS NOTHING.
THAT THEY KNOW OF, THAT THEY
KNOW OF.
>> Sean: LAURA, I HAVE KNOWN
YOU, YOU HAVE A LOT OF
INTERVIEWS WITH ME OVER THE
YEARS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE SEE YOU.
>> Sean: YOUR SON WAS ONLY 18
YEARS OLD.
BRUTALLY BEATEN, MURDERED, SET
ABLAZE.
>> YES.
>> Sean: TELL US THAT STORY.
>> IS AN ABSOLUTE NIGHTMARE, I
SENT JOSH TO SCHOOL ONE DAY AND
HE NEVER CAME HOME.
I STARTED LOOKING AROUND FOR
HIM, AND I FINALLY FOUND HIS
TRUCK PARKED NEXT TO A DUMPSTER,
CALLED POLICE, AND THEY CAME,
CALLED ME OVER, AND EVERYTHING
THAT WAS HIS, HIS SHOES, HIS
STUFF, IN THE DUMPSTER.
WE WAITED IN THE PARKING LOT ALL
EVENING.
FINALLY, THEY ARRESTED A SUSPECT
WHO CAME BACK TO THE CRIME
SCENE, AND THEY ARRESTED HIM
THERE.
WHEN THEY TOOK HIM DOWN TO THE
JAIL, HE HAD JOSHUA'S TRUCK KEY
IN HIS POCKET, AND FINALLY,
24 HOURS LATER, HE TOLD US WHERE
WE COULD FIND IT JOSH.
>> Sean: HE HAD BEEN SET A
FIRE AFTER BEING BRUTALLY
BEATEN.
>> BOUND HIM UP WITH 13 ROPES
AROUND HIS NECK INTO THE BACK OF
HIS HANDS BEHIND HIS BACK,
THROUGH A BELT LOOP, AND THEN TO
HIS FEET, TYING HIM UP SO HE
COULD CARRY HIM, AND THEN HE PUT
HIM IN JOSHUA'S TRUCK AND DROVE
AROUND.
>> Sean: HOW LONG AGO WAS
THIS?
>> 2010.
>> Sean: IT DOESN'T GET
EASIER?
>> NO.
>> Sean: JUST LIKE THE CORE
GRAINS.
>> I FEEL FOR THEM, THEY KNOW
THE STORY, IT IS NOT THEIR STORY
YET.
THAT COMES IN TIME, AND THEN THE
REALLY PAIN BEGINS WHEN THE
SHOCK WEARS OFF AND YOU REALIZE
THAT IT IS FOREVER.
>> Sean: EVERY CHRISTMAS,
EVERYTHING'S GIVEN, EVERY
BIRTHDAY.
>> WHEN YOU FIRST GO HOME, THERE
ARE BOOKS ON THE FLOOR, SOCKS,
IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO GET YOUR
HEART AND HEAD IN THE SAME
PLACE, THEY ARE NOT COMING BACK.
>> Sean: STEVE, I'VE KNOWN YOU
ALSO A COUPLE OF YEARS, I'VE
INTERVIEWED YOU A NUMBER OF
TIMES.
AN AMAZING KID YOU HAD.
YOUR SON WAS 21 YEARS OLD,
GRANT, WORKING IN A CONVENIENCE
STORE, DURING THE GRAVEYARD
SHIFT, MIDNIGHT TO EIGHT SHIFT,
AND INCOMES A A GUY, AND YOUR
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEW
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HES
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HER
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEB
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEI
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEG
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HET
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEE
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HES
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEO
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEE
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HE,
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HER
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HEG
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HET
STORY IT'S VERY INTERESTING, HE?
>> HE CAME INTO BUY A PACK OF
CIGARETTES.
DUMPED A JAR OF CHANGE ON THE
COUNTER, GRANT WENT TO START
COUNTING THE CHANGE WASN'T
COUNTING IT FAST ENOUGH.
SO THE MAN SAID, WHAT, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GIVE MY CIGARETTES?
AND GRAMPS THAT HE HAD TO COUNT
THE THE MAN PRODUCED A GUN,
GRANT DID EVERYTHING HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO, GAVE HIM THE
CIGARETTES.
AS SOON AS THE MAN HAPPY
CIGARETTES, HE WENT AND EXECUTED
GRANT, SHOT HIM POINT BLANK IN
THE FACE, AND THAT IS WHEN HE
ROBBED THE STORE, HE CAME AROUND
THE COUNTER, GRABBED TWO MORE
PACKS OF CIGARETTES.
>> Sean: THAT IS ALL ON VIDEO?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WOULD BE
LIKE WATCHING THE VIDEO, I'M
SURE HORRIFIC FOR YOU.
IT GETS WORSE, THOUGH, BECAUSE
THIS SAME ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT HAD
HELD A YOUNG WOMAN HOSTAGE,
BRUTALLY RAPED HER, IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, HOW DID
HE EVER GET OUT?
AND HOW DID HE NOT GET DEPORTED?
>> HE WAS ABLE TO PLEADED DOWN
HIS CRIMES TO FELONY BURGLARY,
AND JUST GET PROBATION.
>> Sean: HE KIDNAPPED AND
RAPED A WOMAN FOR TEN DAYS,
REPEATEDLY.
>> THEY FOUND HER FULL OF
HEROIN, THEY SAID SHE WAS A DRUG
ADDICT, NOT A RELIABLE WITNESS.
>> Sean: NO, SHE WAS DRUNK.
IT MAKES IT MORE PAINFUL,
KNOWING THEY HAD HIM, KNOWING IF
THEY DID THEIR JOB, THIS IS A
BIG PART OF THIS THING, THERE
ARE TOO MANY INSTANCES WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT -- WE HAVE THEM, WE
IDENTIFY THEM, WE PUT THEM IN
JAIL, AND TALK ABOUT CENTURY
CITIES AND STATES, THEN THEY
WON'T HAND THEM OVER TO I.C.E.
OR THE AID AND ABET THEM IN THE
NEXT CRIME.
SOME OF THESE GUYS HAVE BLOOD ON
THEIR HANDS BY NOT FOLLOWING THE
LAW.
IT IS SO HARD TO HEAR THE
STORIES BECAUSE ALL OF THE
PROMISE YOUR KIDS, THEY ARE SO
YOUNG, 22, 21, 18.
I'M LOOKING AT YOUR SON, AGNES,
HER SON, RONALD, THIS PICTURE,
BY THE WAY, IF I CAN WALK OVER
WITHOUT GETTING ANY SHOT, THAT
IS AT HIS WAKE.
>> THIS IS RONALD IN THE COFFIN,
THIS IS THE REALITY THAT I LIVE
WITH, AND UNLIKE -- THIS IS NOT
MANUFACTURED, I WANT TO TELL THE
DEMOCRATS, THIS IS NOT
MANUFACTURED.
AND I WANT TO CALL ON OUR
PRESIDENT TO PLEASE, IMPLEMENT
E-VERIFY, PLEASE, STOP THE
INSANITY FOR ILLEGAL AND IS TO
COME TO OUR COUNTRY.
AND PUNISH EMPLOYERS, THIS GUY
WOULD BE COMING OUT OF PRISON
NEXT YEAR.
TAKEN AWAY FROM ME AND MY FAMILY
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS
GOING TO COME AFTER ME.
WHY SHOULD HE LIVE?
>> Sean: HE IS GETTING
RELEASED?
>> WITH CALIFORNIA BEING A
SANCTUARY STATE.
>> Sean: THIS HAPPENED IN
2002, WHEN YOU KILL AN INNOCENT
YOUNG MAN, WHY DO YOU EVER GET
OUT OF JAIL?
>> EXACTLY.
HE IS GOING TO GET TO ENJOY HIS
FAMILY, HIS CHILDREN.
ONE OTHER POINT I WANTED TO
MAKE, WHEN NANCY PELOSI SAID ONE
TIME THAT HER CHILD -- HER
GRANDCHILD WAS HAVING A
BIRTHDAY, IT WAS HIS BIRTHDAY
WISH, HE JUST WANTED TO HAVE
BROWN SKIN.
WELL, MY GRAND BUILDER AND,
RONALD'S CHILDREN, WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO MAKE A WISH, TO HAVE
THEIR DAD BACK.
>> Sean: I LOOK AT THAT
PICTURE.
>> LOOK AT HIM, I MISS THAT
SMILE, I MISS HIS BEAR HUG, I
MISS EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM.
MY LIFE CHANGED COMPLETELY
BECAUSE OF THIS.
WHAT IS EVEN MORE OFFENSIVE, I'M
A LEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO FOLLOWED
THE LAW, CAME THROUGH THE RIGHT
CHANNELS, TO THIS COUNTRY.
WHY ISN'T MY COUNTRY AND THE
POLICE OUR POLITICIANS, STANDING
UP FOR ME AND THE AMERICAN
CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTRY?
THEY STAND UP WITH ILLEGAL
ALIENS ON CRIMINALS.
>> Sean: YOU ARE ALL OF THE
FACES.
I WANT AMERICA -- PAN BACK AND
TAKE A LOOK.
THESE ARE THE FACES OF A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE MEDIA SAYS
ABOUT ALL OF YOU AND ALL OF YOUR
EXPERIENCES.
MANUFACTURED?
THESE ARE REAL LIVES.
LOOK AT YOUR BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER,
YOU HAVE A PICTURE.
THIS IS MICHELLE, YOUR DAUGHTER
DAUGHTER'S NAME ISN'T SARAH.
FOR THE SEA?
>> 21, SHE HAD JUST GRADUATED
FROM COLLEGE WITH A 4.0
BACHELORS IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
SHE WAS HIT AND KILLED THAT
NIGHT AFTER CELEBRATING ON HER
WAY HOME.
AND WHEN HE CAME OVER
UNACCOMPANIED AT AGE 16, WAS
DRIVING, NOT EVEN HIS VEHICLE,
STREET RACING, GOING 70 PLUS
MILES PER HOUR.
BLOOD ALCOHOL OF .241.
WHEN HE REAR-ENDED MY DAUGHTER'S
SUV.
>> Sean: THE LEGAL IMMIGRANT
IS .08, AND HE IS .241?
>> THEY LIKE TO SAY IT WAS THREE
TIMES THE LEGAL LIMIT, NO, HE IS
19, HE SHOULD NOT HAVE HAD ANY
ALCOHOL IN HIM.
>> Sean: WHY DID THIS HAPPEN?
>> 2016, JANUARY 31ST IS WHAT WE
CONSIDER HER DEATH DATE BECAUSE
SHE WAS BRAIN-DEAD WHEN THEY GOT
HER TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
HOWEVER, BEING THE LOVELY
CHILD --
>> Sean: AMERICAN, YOUNG,
BEAUTIFUL, 4.0 STUDENT, HER
WHOLE LIFE AND CAREER AHEAD OF
HER.
>> CORRECT.
AND SHE WAS AN ORGAN DONOR, WE
SAVED SIX ADDITIONAL PEOPLE THAT
NIGHT WITH HER ORGANS.
BUT EDWIN MEJIA MADE A BOND
BECAUSE OF THE JUDGE SET A LOW
BOND, AND HE FLED.
SO HE IS OUT THERE.
>> Sean: I'M SO SORRY TO ALL
OF YOU.
I'M SO SORRY.
THIS HAS GOT TO STOP.
THAT IS WHAT THIS SHOW IS ABOUT.
I WANT PEOPLE TO SEE WHAT THIS
MANUFACTURED CRISIS, IT IS NOT
MANUFACTURED.
SHE HAD A RIGHT TO LIVE, YOUR
SON HAD A RIGHT TO LIVE, YOUR
CHILDREN HAD A RIGHT TO LIVE.
I HAVE KNOWN YOU NOW, MARIANNE
MENDOZA, FOR A LONG TIME.
HE IS REALLY HANDSOME.
HE LOOKS LIKE YOU.
GOT HIS GOOD LOOKS.
HE WAS A POLICE OFFICER.
>> HE WAS.
HE WANTED TO BE A POLICE OFFICER
SINCE HE WAS VERY, VERY YOUNG.
ON MAY 11TH, 2014, HE SPENT
MOTHER'S DAY WITH ME AND WENT
INTO WORK, AND WAS GOING TO COME
BACK FOR DESSERT, HE HAD COME
FOR DINNER, AND HE SAID MOM, I'M
TOO BUSY, CAN'T COME IN.
THE EARLY HOURS OF MAY 12TH,
2014, HE WAS ON HIS WAY HOME
FROM WORK, AND AN ILLEGAL ALIEN,
REPEAT CRIMINAL, HAD GONE OVER
35 MILES THE WRONG WAY ON FOUR
DIFFERENT FREEWAYS, HIGH ON
METH, LEGAL LIMIT DRAWN, HIS
FAMILY LET HIM DRIVE REPEATEDLY
TO LEAVE A HOUSE, KEEP GOING
BACK AND FORTH.
HE SLAMMED HEAD-ON INTO MY SON,
AND I GOT A CALL, QUARTER TO
THREE IN THE MORNING FROM
AFGHANISTAN, A FELLOW OFFICER
WHO WAS AN INTERNATIONAL GUARD,
TELLING ME HE HAD BEEN IN A
TERRIBLE ACCIDENT.
I KEPT TRY TO CALL HIS PHONE, HE
WASN'T ANSWERING, AND THEN MY
WORST NIGHTMARE, THE DOORBELL
RANG AND IT WAS POLICE TO TAKE
ME TO THE HOSPITAL.
HE DIED.
>> Sean: I'VE TRIED TO PUT
MYSELF IN YOUR SHOES, I THINK
PARENTS CAN DO THAT.
THIS IS THE ONE THING I DON'T
THINK YOU RECOVER FROM.
I DON'T CARE HOW STRONG YOU
THINK YOU ARE, YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO RECOVER FROM THIS.
>> NO, AND THIS IS NOT A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS, THIS IS
WHERE I HAVE TO GO FOR HIS
BIRTHDAY, FOR CHRISTMAS, FOR
EVERY HOLIDAY.
JUST AS RECENTLY -- MICHELLE WAS
AT MY HOUSE IN PHOENIX, I HAVE
THREE PEOPLE CONTACTING ME FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS LATER, TALKING
ABOUT THE THINGS MY SON HAD DONE
FOR THEM.
THIS HAS BEEN A CONTINUAL, FOR
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS.
>> Sean: DOES THE MEDIA ASK
YOU FOR INTERVIEWS?
I KNOW I'VE INTERVIEWED YOU MANY
TIMES.
YOU BEEN ON MANY TIMES.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR THE
STORY?
AND THEN THEY ARROGANTLY GO ON
TV, YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT.
>> ONE MORE PICTURE.
>> Sean: YES, MA'AM.
>> THIS IS 330 MILES OF OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER IN ARIZONA.
330 MILES, AND IT IS A LIBERAL
POLITICIANS THINK THIS IS GOING
TO KEEP CRIMINALS OUT OF OUR
COUNTRY, THEY ARE INSANE.
>> Sean: INSANE, INSENSITIVE,
CRUEL, CALLOUS, IN A SENSE,
SANCTUARY CITIES AND STATES.
FROM THAT MOMENT FORWARD THAT
THEY RELEASE PEOPLE, AND IT